Okay, thanks for coming. Uh,
I'll introduce our main speaker.
Amy Kurzweil have known her for 30 years.
It's a first vote, Huh? Yeah. That,
that was planned.
So she's written a great book.
Uh,
she actually wrote it started
as a senior thesis at, uh,
Stanford.
And finally three or four years later,
it was finished and everybody
is finally relieved. Okay.
You're going to get it out.
And she looked sitting there.
The illustrations at the end are much
better than the ones at the beginning.
So I have to do it over and everyone
is calm. I got this. Uh, so,
but she got that done and then only
another three or four years. Uh,
it's a very labor intensive
process. It's, it's a great book.
Uh, if I say so from our
family's perspective, uh,
but other people have liked it.
And New York,
it was a editor's pick
by the New York Times.
They put it on their list of the best
graphic novels or 2016 Kirkus reviews said
it was one of the best memories of 2016.
Um,
and so we,
we will talk about that,
but we'll talk about some
other collaborative projects
cause we've actually
worked,
um,
quite a few things as we went
through it for this presentation.
Uh, she's, uh, her comics
had been in the New Yorker,
a New Yorker.
I had a compilation of the best cartoons
in the New Yorker for 2016 and two of
our cartoons when they are in, she'll
show, she'll share some of those with you.
Uh, she's been a number
of other publications. Uh,
Shenandoah, the toast, they all,
she has a ba from Stanford University
and the MFA from the new school.
She's an adjunct professor of writing
comics at Parsons and the Fashion
Institute of Technology.
So welcome Amy as well.
Thanks Dad.
Thank you everyone for having
me. This is such a pleasure. Um,
so I'm going to introduce the man
who needs no introduction. Uh,
you probably know Ray Kurzweil.
He's been director of engineering
here at Google for over four years.
A director, a director, uh,
works on natural language,
understanding his inventions
include, uh, the flatbeds, Danner,
omnifont OCR, a large
vocabulary, speech recognition,
realistic music synthesis. He's been
awarded the National Medal of Technology,
inducted into the inventor's hall of fame.
He has 21
honorary doctorates, a grammy, and he's
written five national bestselling books.
Not Bad.
Okay.
You might not know,
however that one of his lesser known but
still very significant achievements is
that he plays a bit part in the
smash hit graphic memoir, flying cow,
doing such important things
as helping me get to sleep.
That's so thank you dad for that.
I'm going to tell you a bit about flying
couch before we move on to other things.
Uh, this is the story of
three generations of women,
the first myself young artists.
And the second is my mother also
happens to be the wife of Ray Kurzweil.
Uh, Sonia Kurzwell. She's
a psychologist. And uh,
last but not least, my grandmother,
my mother's mother, Lily Fenster,
she's 90 years old. We just came
from seeing her in Naples, Florida,
where I did a book event down there.
She was so excited.
She hasn't changed a bit in 42 years.
Yeah.
Here she is as a young
woman. Um, when I show up.
So we did this presentation in Naples,
Florida,
and she was there in the audience the
first time that she's ever been in the
audience while I've been
talking about the book.
And she was just interrupting every
five seconds. Exuberantly like she saw.
She's like, where did you
get that picture? You know,
she was so excited about everything.
And then also in some moments, uh,
it was difficult for her to watch
because in this story flying couch,
I'm telling about her early life during
the Holocaust when she left the worst
ghetto survived on her own.
She was the only person who survived.
So it's a difficult story but
also an exuberant story. Um,
the best way to give you the flavor of
the book is to show you this animated
book trailer that I slaved over. So,
um, those of you who are animators,
I have much respect for your work
so you understand what we're doing.
I am this then us questions.
So I just say I'm lowly fence the night.
My whole look was her revive it. Okay.
So tell everyone about yourself,
huh?
How do you feel about being a character?
In my book,
I love it mean be Dick head
and it's mostly like cut, cut,
cut, kind of the at you. Paramount.
So you know, but why did you
pick that? I have no idea.
Who would light the number? Old Jewish
woman. Is it going to be successful
showing you? I use a Ph d
child, 10 colleges for children.
I arranged this.
My kids,
I called Amy has a heart of gold.
She goes my first granddaughter and he
wants to feel what they went through.
Well, I'm thinking I would like
it to get married. One Kid Hammer.
We should stick together.
Then chaplains that you flesh.
If you gave a good family life,
you ever good light? You survive.
Yeah.
Do you want to sing something?
You want me to sit and get a thing?
Should I sing in Jewish?
If you want to hear my grandmother's
thing, that can be a ranch.
Okay,
so you started writing this
book eight years ago. Why?
Why was this a story you want it
to tell them what took you so long?
Well, as I said, I had to draw it twice.
So that's why it took so long. Um,
so this project started when I
was in college and my mother, um,
gave me this transcript that my
grandmother had done with a historian,
Holocaust historian at the
University of Michigan. And she, uh,
she painstakingly and in a lot of
detailed told about everything that had
happened to her. Of course,
not in a totally linear way,
but everything was recorded. All these
memories, things that I hadn't heard, um,
all at once, but that I'd heard
pieces of for my whole life. And, uh,
things like, um, her,
her early family life,
things like that I never knew about or
the antisemitism that existed in Europe
before the war.
Um,
the story of her sneaking through
the wall and the Warsaw ghetto,
there was a few bricks and she was skinny,
so she snuck out through the wall. Um,
I'd heard fragments of these stories,
but I've never really put
them into a coherent whole.
And I never really understood exactly
what that might mean for me to grow up in
the shadow of such a dramatic history.
Um,
it affects you and it's
not exactly clear how, um,
so I was a relatively normal kid,
um,
sensitive and spent a lot of time
involved in my creative pursuits.
Not technologically inclined necessarily,
but I'm creating my own world.
And normal is irrelative.
Yeah.
I had some strange habits
or strange bends of mind,
certain curiosities about dark things
and curiosities about this history.
And it felt to me like I
had to look at it closely.
Um, here's an example of maybe
being a little strange a kid.
Did anybody use to do that thing where
you watch your eyes dilate in the mirror?
Yeah. So you can learn about some
of my other neuroses in the book,
but that's one of the,
um,
but the main thing that
spurred my interest in the
story was when I left home to
go to Stanford,
which was those of you who've been there,
it's not that far from here. It's just
a paradise of comfort and privilege.
But I was really very anxious about
leaving home and it didn't make a lot of
sense to me. You know, my life
was relatively comfortable.
Why would I have so much
anxiety about leaving home?
And when I started to learn more about
my grandmother's story about how she left
home under these certain circumstances,
I started to think that there
was something I'd inherited,
some sort of fear. And,
and writing this book was
the way that I explored that.
I mean,
I also heard,
I've heard a little fragments and bits
and pieces of lowly story over the years,
but there were little fragments.
And until I read Amy's book,
I really didn't have a coherent
linear narrative of it.
So it was quite a revelation to
actually get the story in the,
in the linear sequence.
Something that I like about the book,
it's really combines the holocausts with
Umer Umer both of Amy's coming of age
and,
and humor of Lily herself in
her current circumstances.
That's very hard combination to pull off.
I think the only other time I've seen
that in the work of is it's a beautiful
life, the movie, but, but they're,
the humor is part of the story.
The farther uses humor to
keep his son Zane. But anyway,
so it's a hard combination.
So I remember Amy's early efforts in
animation and drawing when she was in,
I think 10th grade I attended,
it was bring your parents to school day.
And so I attended her math class and
she's like drawing these little drawings
and Casey and looking up at the board,
well obviously that angle is equal to
that one. Minus. I won. I said, Amy,
that's really good math thinking since
this, it's not math thinking, it's,
it's obvious that angle has to be equal
to that one and yet subtract that and
said, well, I said, well,
when you understand something
it always seems obvious.
So we're very concerned here with girls
dropping out of math and stem in high
school,
which seems to be a phenomena and
we'd like to see more girls and women,
uh, you know, entering these fields.
Amy Fortunately had and has other skills,
but she is a good mathematician.
So
we need more programmers than our day
card groups and we may recruit her and,
but, but she is busy with other
projects that she'll tell you about.
So, uh, but how did you
transition to comics?
Cause you at Stanford do studied
writing and you had this background in
illustration.
When did you come to combine those two?
Yeah.
Well yeah,
my drawing career before this book was
mostly just drawing during math class.
That was the main way that I got to
be an artist because they need to do
something about the way they teach math.
I think that's,
but that's a whole other
panel. Um, so yeah,
I mean I was interested in drawing and
I was interested in writing and I didn't
think to put the two together until I read
certain books, like mouse for example,
which is another book that it
combines humor in the Holocaust,
but it's a short list of
things that do that. Um,
but mouse is definitely on that list.
And there's something interesting about,
um, about drawing. So we've,
somebody taught me that storytelling
is one of our first technologies.
I wonder who told me that.
Um,
and there was oral storytelling and
then there was written storytelling.
Um, and it, it feels like
one progressed to the other,
but there's this other thing in the middle
there which is drawing. Um, there's,
there have been cave drawings
discovered, you know, 50,000 BCE. Um,
and so people, early humans were
recording their lives that way.
And there's something about drawing and
comics that they get a little bit of a
bad rap for being unsophisticated or
being associated with children, um,
because they tap into something that I
think is more primitive and it really is
more primitive. Um, but that's not
necessarily necessarily a dig against it.
When you draw, you are much more, um,
directly expressing something about
what you feel or what you see. Um,
and so Scott McCloud, the writer of
understanding comics, it's a great book.
People should read if they're interested.
He talks about the
iconic obstruction scale.
And over here you have images,
um,
the least abstract way of
representing the world.
So like a photograph for example,
it's very close to what we actually see.
And then in the middle here you have
symbols and simplistic drawings, emojis.
Um, and then over here on the
other spectrum, we have words, uh,
which are the most
abstracted from reality.
And we take for granted
that words are abstract,
abstract because we dealt
with them all the time,
but it requires more levels of abstraction
in order to understand the symbols
that we call words.
Um,
and so I think that's why drawing
gets associated with what is child or
primitive because it actually is
associated with something that takes less
levels of abstracting to understand.
But what's cool about comics is
that it mixes the two together.
And so that mix is so sophisticated
if people use the form correctly.
And so once I discovered that it
was like a revelation, it was,
it was so magical and I was just hooked.
Is there a comics particularly good
at describing visceral emotional
experiences? I mean, what's
your relationship there?
I said storytelling is the technology
and I think storytelling is mostly a
technology. Well, it does a lot of things,
but one thing it does really well is
create empathy and drawing because it's so
connected to the what's
visceral, um, and what's,
you know, um, like this is a good example.
What can't be expressed or,
or what's felt? Um, I think
it's that much better at,
at inducing empathy and readers. Something
I noticed when I'm drawing is it's,
and it's very difficult for me to
ever draw a facial expression. Um,
like for example, trying to represent
something like fear or anxiety.
I can't draw it without having
to form it on my own face.
And you can experiment with
that. It's very difficult. Um,
and I can't draw,
you know,
tension or exuberance or some abstraction
without bringing the quality into my
arm. And so in this really
immediate, interesting way,
drawing brings feelings that you're
trying to represent into your own body.
And so my grandmother talked about,
I wanted to tell this story because I
want it to feel what she went through.
I didn't just want to know it or
understand it. I want it to feel it.
And drawing helped me do that. It helped
me access that direct empathetic mode.
This makes me want to
ask you some questions.
We were talking about how,
um,
comics have this kind of
modus of sophistication, um,
comics.
In order to read a comic,
you have to do something that's
common cloud calls closure.
So you see one image and you see another
image and you have to knit the two
together in order to create
a sequence in your mind.
And a lot of that's happening in unlike
film where that happens for you with
comics has happening,
you have to do that work yourself.
And so I've thought about what that
work is like and because you have taught
machines to read,
um,
first with the reading machine and now
with natural language understanding here,
Google,
how hard would it be to teach
a computer to read comics?
Is that a harder problem?
I've got a few members of
my team here and uh, yes,
I think that would be quite
challenging. Uh, Brian,
this smirking I think,
uh,
realizing how difficult
a problem that would be.
So we were making good progress
and understanding language.
We can start to do things
like summarization and we
have different tasks that
require actually understanding
semantics of language.
And Google has very good image
recognition that people are familiar with.
Big accusation against the
field was five or six years ago,
is that you guys can't even tell the
difference between a dog and a cat.
Now we can do that.
Uh,
and turns out the essence of a dog and
a cat is at level 15 of a deep neural
net. And we couldn't go beyond three or
four levels because of a math problem.
Just a five or six years ago has to do
with keeping convicts ever era surfaces.
But anyway, it's a math problem. We
could create 10 20 level neural nets,
but the information disintegrated
around the fifth level.
So that problem was solved and now we
could go to 2000 level neural nets.
And once we pass a level 15,
they could tell the difference
between a dog and a cat.
And now thousands of other categories.
And the Google image recognition program
can tell cats and dogs and cows and you
know, 20 different varieties of
birds, but also things like sunsets,
autumn love,
other kind of more a femoral,
uh, characteristics. And it
really does a very good job.
This is not a Google project,
but it shows the power of deep learning.
In our Descartes group,
we have a different approach to
deep learning based on my book,
how to create a mind, which is basic
hierarchies of models of sequences.
This was done with a deep neural net,
but you can give it an image like this
is just a photograph. And then say,
we'll repaint that same age in
the style of Van Gogh and this,
uh,
or Picasso
or munch, uh, who did the scream. He's,
that's an actual image. And, uh,
so it's redoing that picture
of Ralph buildings, uh,
in these different styles.
So computers are taking
steps in the arts and uh,
they're not getting human levels.
But, uh, I've been saying 20, 29,
uh, the AI field, there's
been periodic polls.
We're getting closer, but not
because I'm changing my view. Uh,
when I first said 2029 and my 1999
book age of spiritual machines,
uh,
Stanford held a conference to deal with
this startling prediction and it took a
poll and the median was about 500 years.
Uh,
recently.
I was just actually at a
seminar or conference, uh,
not named after this room,
but uh,
really to establish AI ethics
based on the original list. Uh,
biotech is telemark conference,
which is now 40 years old. Uh,
and there was a poll presented.
The median was 50 years.
It's actually not because,
uh,
I mean part of my thesis is
the acceleration of progress.
Proctors keeps getting faster
and information technology
grows exponentially and
I don't think there's actually a lot more
appreciation of that than they used to
be, but people, the actual
rate of progress now has,
is in fact a lot faster
than it was in 1999.
So peep people look at the current
rate of progress and saying, well,
at the current rate of pockets, I think
it's going to take 50 years. And in 1999,
they looked at the current
rate of progress as well.
I think at this rate of progress
is going to take about 500 years.
I agreed with both of those. I think at
the rate of progress in 19 nine, nine,
it would take 5,500 years and
it's right in practice today.
It would take 50 years,
but the rate of progress is
going to continue to get faster.
We're going to make 50 years a progress
at today's rate of progress in 13 years.
Um,
anyway,
people are getting more optimistic and
these are sort of turning complete tasks
or acquire all of human intelligence
in any implications of that,
both in terms of promise
versus peril employment, uh,
consciousness of computers.
Should we worry about causing pain and
suffering to our computer software? Uh,
people are more concerned today about
the opposite and software causing us pain
and suffering. But yeah. Um,
well speaking about the future of art,
um,
we can talk a little bit about our first
collaboration that we did together.
Yeah.
Way Back in 2001 when I was
14 and still had braces,
I was roped into doing this a while.
I was granted the opportunity to take
part in this historic Ted Conference,
um,
where we were presenting the promise of
virtual reality and virtual spaces being
places where you can be
whoever you want to be,
which reminds me of writing, um, and the,
the way we get to inhabit
different characters and writing.
And so we did this project.
My father transformed into
Ramona who's a rage rock singer.
And I unfortunately do not have
as much say in my transformation.
I was transformed into three.
Um,
I got to expand my identity across bodies,
three male backup dancers who were
middle aged and no bit overweight,
I have to say,
and not wearing shirts and
modeled in the image of Richard Saul
Wurman who is the Ted Empresario at the
time.
And so I can't find any images of this
online and I wonder if he's responsible
for taking them down. So,
yeah. Do you want to talk,
talk about this?
I mean, you're in Vr. This
was in 2001 at 10. Uh,
Vr was very primitive. We had a lot
of problems with the technology,
but both Amy and I were wearing magnetic
sensors and as removed these life size
avatars on a big screen,
moved in sync with us.
They were kind of digital puppets of ours,
quite had,
uh, there were technical issues,
but it worked well enough.
We pulled it off the performance.
So the idea was you can be
someone else in virtual reality.
You don't have to be the same
boring person all the time.
Present company excluded.
Um,
and so I tried to fix him and
that was different from myself.
And same with Amy.
Richard Saul Wurman was not known
for his hip hop cakes, but uh,
her avatar was actually very realistic.
Um,
but uh, you can actually go
to go to the web, uh, if you,
if you're just put in the,
uh, in Google Ramona songs,
Kurzweil, you can these here, uh,
the songs I sang,
I sang white rabbit at Gracie slick
song and then a song I wrote myself a,
and you can hear it both with and
without the gender modification. Uh,
it came,
came out pretty well.
I think this is one of the promises
of virtual reality right now.
The VR that's coming out, it's fairly
static. You basically are in a VR world.
There's some technical issues with it.
I think the real promise is that you
can be an actor in it and interact with
other people,
but you don't actually have to be the
same person and you can actually change
other people to be who you want them
to be. Uh, so these are some of them.
We tried to show this in 2001 so that
was our first collaboration, Huh?
Yeah. I mean, I'm curious,
I want to ask you about this idea
of identity in virtual reality.
Conceivably we might spend more and more
time in these spaces as they get more
sophisticated and this idea that you
can be anyone that you want to be.
Um, that's interesting to me because
theoretically that's true in writing,
but in the writing world, there is
actually sensitivity about, for example,
taking on identities that you don't really
have insight into, sir. So, you know,
a white person writing in
the voice of a black person.
Sometimes there's some questions
about that. Um, or appropriate.
And cultures in general,
people are,
they have questions and sometimes
get offended about those kinds of
transformations.
I'm often rightfully so.
And then sometimes there are times
in which transforming our identities,
you know,
like gender transitions is celebrated
and encouraged and virtual reality seems
like a really promising place for,
um, something like that. You know,
somebody who wants to really embody a
different gender and they don't have to
have complicated surgery.
So do you think that virtual reality will
have the same identity politics as we
see in real reality?
Well,
it is interesting that people really
begin to identify with their avatar and
they seem to transfer their
consciousness even if it's a simple game.
Um, it was actually interesting, uh,
incident recently I've been writing how
virtual reality is inherently safer.
I mean, ultimately we can be in virtual
environments that are just as real.
It's real reality. But one advantage
of virtual reality is you can hang up.
So telephone call is virtual
reality as far as soon, uh,
talking, uh, as far as far as
the auditory sense is concerned.
But you can hang up on a phone call
if you don't like where it's going.
There's usually an incident where a woman,
uh,
claimed quite sincerely that she had
been assaulted in virtual reality.
And I had been writing
how you really from that,
I still think virtual reality is safer
because if Chavis he didn't like this
interaction and happening quickly enough
that she wasn't able to leave and she
was densified enough with her avatar that
she didn't like what this other avatar
did to her avatar.
But it wasn't my avatar.
She felt it was her because people
do transfer their consciousness.
She could then leave that experience.
So at least she could stop the
continuation of a interaction.
She didn't like what you can't
always do in real reality.
So I do think it's safer,
but I thought it was interesting cause
I really hadn't expected that you could
be assaulted in virtual reality,
but cause you could be in a phone call
to when someone could say something that
you feel is assaultive. And, uh,
so virtual reality is the term I think
is unfortunate because virtual reality
makes it sound like it's not
real reality. So you know, if,
if you and I make an agreement on the
phone and say, oh, well, but that was,
you know, virtual reality, that
wasn't a real agreement. Um,
it is real reality. Yeah.
It's just in a different form.
So the same rules might
apply. Yeah. So I mean, I,
there are a ways that it's safer,
but there's also ways it's more
dangerous because people can be there
anonymously.
You don't even know who they are.
And some people feel like it can take
more liberties and they're doing real
reality.
Uh,
both parties are sort of less protected,
but that can be,
uh, I mean we see all the time people
anonymously communicate things that they
wouldn't otherwise do if we
knew who they were. Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's interesting thinking
about storytelling as
something that induces empathy,
a technology of empathy.
It's interesting for me to think about
virtual reality experiences becoming a
mode of storytelling.
Like you literally enter somebody else's
life and you actually see what it's
like to, you're not necessarily
saying, now I am this person,
but you get this really immersive sense
of somebody's life and you have that
experience and it's, it's sounds like, um,
there's a,
there's,
there's potential to identify so strongly
with that experience that you actually
forget to have empathy for it or you end
up being traumatized by the experience.
It's, it's interesting to me that in, in
art and storytelling and even in film,
you still have this removal
from the experience.
And I think that that distance from the
experience is important because it gives
you the space to reflect and to say,
oh, I'm watching this thing and, um,
I have this distance from it in order to
reflect on what it is and what it might
mean. We can move you enough to, to cry
or it happened. I mean, yeah, definitely.
Um,
it's,
it seems interesting to me that in
virtual reality where we're losing and
closing that distance,
and is that,
is there any danger there for the ability
to really feel empathy for the people
that we become in virtual reality?
Well, I mean, potentially
being more immersive, uh,
we can be more effective.
And I mentioned this anecdote about this
woman feeling assaulted and that that
was kind of startling to me. Um, but,
uh,
I think there is danger and that I think
we will move to an era where we're at
least in augmented reality all the time.
Uh,
and that has the potential of increasing
empathy because we'll be able to be
with people that we want to be with.
But then people may enter the, uh,
the, uh, situation that we didn't invite.
We certainly see that.
And social media.
Yeah. Well they're still
be experiences, um,
that are called,
well,
there'd be virtual reality experiences
that we call art and others that we just
call something else,
like, just experience.
Because what we talked
a little bit about art,
the roots of the word art being
connected to the word artificial.
And that route, meaning, um,
trickery and crafts craftsmanship and
that an inherent in the concept of art is
that we are, that it's separate
from us and that it's not real.
And so I wonder, these VR experiences
that we call art, what will,
what will make them art
if there's so immersive?
Well, I think it's the same thing as, as
with, uh, anything else. I mean, you, uh,
Gordon Bell invented
life pitch in the 80s,
so you could record your whole life and
then you could do something like the
movie John Being John Malcovich where
you could actually inhabit someone else's
body. And that's actually just about
feasible today. Yeah. Um, let's see.
Out of their eyes here,
out of their ears that,
that's fairly straightforward
feel out of their skin. I mean,
there's ways of beginning to do that.
Um,
but that's not necessarily
art, uh, artists,
when you select certain subset of,
of our reality to give
you some insight into,
into deeper truths about,
about life.
Yeah.
It seems to me that in virtual reality,
a whole concept of identity
will be totally different.
And the things that are connected to our
physical bodies are going to be less.
It was very interesting
when I became Ramona,
how many just kind of interesting. But
I felt it was actually quite liberating.
The glow. I really felt like I
transferred my consciousness.
I was looking in a mirror and I was
somebody else and I felt more relative to,
okay, I happen to have this
particular physical body,
but that's not the only way to be.
I really could be someone else.
People very much identify,
I'm this skinny teenage girl,
I'm the so will wait, middle aged
man. But you can be someone else.
And it'll be actually interesting
when you can have, you know,
full immersive virtual experiences
with other people being someone else.
And uh,
I think that I could potentially increase
empathy because you can realize what
it's like to be someone else.
Yeah. Especially if you can experience
their stories and their histories.
Because so much of identity isn't just
the way we look, but the history is like,
as my book was exploring,
the histories that we inherit are the
kinds of experiences we have because of
the way we look and we can really
simulate those experiences.
Then I think that relapse,
that's where are,
cause you've got to be selective
and you tell that story.
I mean you can't tell the
20th story in 20 years.
So you pick the incidents that are,
they really make a point.
Well, speaking of transferring
our consciousness,
maybe you can also tell us a little bit
about your first foray into one kind of
virtual world,
which is the world of fiction.
Yeah. So in this Vr, some thing at Ted,
Amy taught me how to actually move like a
female,
which did not come naturally to me.
Um,
but uh,
I've been thinking a lot about,
uh,
intelligence since I've written
books about nonfiction books,
about intelligence. And I
think once computers, region,
human intelligence say you automatically
will be super human intelligent.
Um,
you know,
we've been using computers as it is
to make up for weaknesses and our
intelligence, we can't remember more
than the handful of phone numbers. Uh,
most people here could
recite the alphabet.
But if I ask you to recite it backwards,
you can't do that.
That's a trivial thing
for computers to do.
It's a computer's already do a
lot of things that we can't do.
They can remember a billion or
trillion ton numbers easily.
Um, but I thought really, uh,
illustrate this a,
I started to imagine what would
it be like if one person and, uh,
a young girl happened to
be half superintelligence.
And I don't actually explain that.
Uh,
have a preface to the novel were saying,
well, this does someone like Danielle,
who's, it's very super intelligent girl,
exists in the world today. And I said,
well, from one perspective, anybody can
be a Danielle. And we have young people,
certainly college students who do things
like start Google or apple or Microsoft.
And we have high school kids now
that are doing amazing things.
And I think anybody who has the courage
to pursue their ideas and to overcome
sort of artificially,
uh,
imposed limitations and our thinking in
our confidence in what we can do to the
world can be a Danielle and make
dramatic changes in the world.
Uh, then I said, well, does
anyone actually exists?
It has the broad range of Danielle's
superpowers has superpowers not melting
steel with our eyes. It's melting problems
with her intellect and her artistry.
And I said, well, perhaps not yet.
So this book is a thought experiment.
What if someone with Danielle's confidence
and courage and an intellect existed,
what would that mean for the
world? Uh, and then I say,
now imagine if we were all Danielle's
and that will happen by the year 20,
45. So my publisher said, well,
we need a backstory cause you
know, superman has a backstory. And
I said,
well,
I'd rather give my backstory as to why I
wrote this novel cause I didn't want to
say, well she's a girl and she's fused
with AI and our brain or something.
It would seem to pat.
But anyway,
she's a girl who follows
her from zero to 22.
Um,
and she does remarkable things.
She goes to Zambia at age six and
solves part of the water problem.
She becomes a worldwide
country music stars.
Page h he overthrows Kadafi
was software viruses at age 10.
She cures cancer at age 12.
She brings democracy to
China at age 14 and becomes,
it's first democratically
elected president. Um,
she becomes present United States at
age 19 by defeating Hillary Clinton.
Um, that'd be a better choice. So,
uh,
W W I made a VR trailer we can't show
you via yet for an audience of the site.
We'll show it to you in two D.
Right?
How long do I have? Precisely. 11 minutes.
Really starting to sink in that I've
actually been elected chairman of the
Communist Party of China. Some
people seem surprised because, well,
I'm a 15 year old girl from Los Angeles.
I suppose part of me is surprised too,
but the other part has been expecting it.
It's been a complicated path to get here.
I started out innocuously
as a child that didn't talk.
I didn't really see the point of it
at least until I had something to say.
I loved books I taught myself to read,
but I didn't want people to know.
I purposefully held my book upside down
to throw my sister Claire off track.
Clear by the way,
was an orphan from the Haitian earthquake
that mom and dad adopted two years
before I was born.
Okay.
Well, I finally joined the conversation
and said my first words when I was two.
My mom was shocked at my insights into
the word on him on a pia and dropped the
blueberry dessert all over. Claire
and me. The Dad took it in stride.
It wasn't very good at making friends.
Well,
at least the other kids had a good time.
At my fourth birthday party,
I finally made my first friend
when I was six in Zambia,
halfway around the world. I went there
with Claire to help with the drought.
We ran into a lot of predicaments
like feuding warlords.
By my calculation, we solved one
third of 1% of the water problem.
The world discovered me at eight when
I was debuting at the country music
festival,
but I learned that fame has a steep price.
The peace conference that
clear organized in Libya.
It turned out to be kind of a disaster.
I ended up protecting the rebels and my
sister with software viruses from our
outpost in the Libyan desert.
Negotiating a Middle East peace agreement
was more complicated than I expected,
but I had help from a
wise rabbi in Brooklyn.
Tragedy struck when I was 14 I discovered
that there is an unrelenting banality
to debt. Well, I better gather my
thoughts and my acceptance speech.
I'm the first teenage girl to be elected
chairman of the Communist Party of
China and I'm not even Chinese.
I have to say I'm not really
comfortable with that title of chairman.
How about chair woman? No,
that doesn't make sense.
Either 15 someone suggested id just
called chair and I'm not a piece of
furniture.
I've got a chair girl
[inaudible].
Amy was my writing coach for fiction,
which is actually quite
different than nonfiction.
You need is a character arcs and you need
a story arc. Every story is the same.
It has a,
what's called a Christian arc.
The character runs into problems and then
more problems and then all is lost and
then the bottom falls out
and it's completely helpless.
And then there's the
resurrection at the end.
Let me look at stories you'll see
that they all follow that aren't, um,
anyway that Amy did the illustrations.
Um,
and there was an interplay between
writing the story and the illustration.
Could she write an illustration that say,
oh,
that's what Danielle was thinking and
what are you seeing this character in your
mind does he wrote? Yes, actually it had
fantasies about Danielle and for years.
And finally I'm one vacation,
but six years ago decided to write them
down and had draft one of the novel.
But I had the long way to go to
understand the craft of storytelling,
which as you pointed out with the
first, our first technology. Um,
but then your illustrations actually
helped me to understand the stories that
there was an interaction there. What'd
you say a little bit about your next,
yeah. Novel. Well, the next part of that,
I'm working on the beginning
of our collaborations.
This is Fred Kurzwell,
a father of my father.
And some of you might know if you saw
the movie transcendent man that my father
has this collection of documents and
artifacts that he saved from his father.
And I'm in a storage unit.
I've actually been to this storage unit.
At first it was like definitely
haunted. Um, it was in this,
you know, dark, all these dark
alleys and nobody else was there.
And like floors and floors of different
storage units and the lights would turn
off if you weren't moving.
And it was the very horrifying,
I had an interesting
experience there. Um, and,
and now you've moved those documents
to a less haunted building,
which makes her not as
good as story. But, uh,
so it's interesting to me why you've
been saving all these documents.
Theoretically,
we will come to have such sophisticated
AI that we could take these documents
along with memories and recreate an Avatar
of this person who died quite young.
Um, and I'm really
interested in, you know,
what that might look like
and why we might do that. Um,
and for me store,
you know,
stories especially in
flying couch had such a,
a meaning to my present life, the past
and its relationship to the present, uh,
has given my life a lot of meaning.
And it's things like something
I've had a lot of questions about.
And so with this,
if you can actually take the past and
make it literally a part of the present by
bringing somebody back, um,
what does that mean? What,
what does that going to do for our
sense of self and our relationships?
And so I'm curious to explore that in my,
in my next,
well, I mean that was the theme
of the movie transcendent man.
We can create a chat bot today.
We have the technology to take a corpus
of writings and create a chat Bot that
represents that person likes you planted.
Do that with my father's writings
as we did that with Danielle.
Actually you can talk to Danielle,
but it's not that human levels yet.
I think ultimately wouldn't be x.
You can pass a chain test.
One of the implications is we could
create a someone that is very much human
like and that reflects all the
information we have about them,
even their DNA and uh,
recollections of other people
and all of their artifacts.
I mean,
what's interesting is as a writer or
something you're trying to do is to do as
much research as you can and then trust
your intuition about how to write about
real people who lived. Um, so
with my grandmother's story,
I had to trust my intuition and I had a
certain amount of information and I was
able to bring her to the
page and I'm wondering,
will an AI one do that process
better than I can, you know,
will they have access to more information
and potentially have more emotional
nuance? Like, am I going to
be out of a job? Probably.
My view is it's not us versus them.
We're going to use AI to make
ourselves smarter. We do that now.
We carry these ais on our belts and who
here could do their work or anyone in
the world can they do their work or
their education without these brain
extenders already have. And then we're
going to get more intimate with them.
We're going to put them in our brains.
We're going to connect
our brains to the cloud.
So we'll be actually better at
doing these kinds of things.
So if we could just take a
couple of minutes in the shares,
some of your cartoons,
a similar one,
the first one you had in the New Yorker.
My first New Yorker cartoon
was Google inspired.
This is the first one.
Do you guys have any studious
Google cars around who are,
um,
am I second cartoon was
Rhode Island.
I don't know. So probably
close to doing that, but uh,
we both have robot cats.
I got mine for Hanukkah
last year and it's very,
robots are very funny to me.
I've,
I've draw a lot of inspiration
from artificial intelligence, um,
for my cartoons because there's just
something about robots in their current
form that is like, you're, you're
like, you feel for it. You know,
you want it to be more, you know, because
you're like, just try a little harder.
You can be human or you can really be a
cat, you know. Um, and this robot car,
we have it, it's pretty crude and, but
I was thinking, you know, to be a cat,
it's not that hard actually. You just
have to just have to sit there. Um,
so yeah,
I draw,
I draw a lot of inspiration from are
my dad's worked for sources of humor as
well as more profound thanks.
But you know,
humor is humor and humor is
connected to what's profound.
I think we find things funny because
they really resonate with something true
about our condition. Um,
so I thought to wrap up,
I'd show you guys some of my unpublished
cartoons and you can help me figure out
which ones are the best.
So I can, you know,
go to Bob Makeup at the
New Yorker and be like,
everyone at Google said that this one.
And I know that there's a partnership,
something, you know, a partnership
between the cartoon editor in Google.
So maybe he'll, maybe you guys can help me
out. All right, so here's the first one.
Good.
All right.
The future of art.
Cool.
How went,
took a second.
Okay.
That's how I would like to play golf.
You never know who you're offending me.
I think that's a good place to end.
Okay.
So cool questions,
comments.
Hi.
So it's interesting that you brought up
the one panel two panel inferring what
happened in between the panels in a
comic for the things that people write or
something like the panels in the story
of their life and the getting an AI to
speak in the voice of someone else using
these panels involves inferring what's
in between those two panels.
There was actually a black mirror episode
about doing that and it hitting the
uncanny valley.
How do you think human storytelling as
a technology could be transferred into
doing this for robots?
It's interesting what you say.
I can only speak from a
writer's perspective that you
do so much writing before.
What you put on the page is if
you know, inked or is printed, um,
you really have to have a full sense of
a character before you can write them
convincingly.
And so much of that is unsaid and that's
sort of what minimalism is about and
it's what any good writing is about.
And I think that's why people feel
that in order to ride really well,
a certain character,
you need to know so much about them,
which is why bridging racial or cultural
divides, it's so hard for writing. Um,
and so yeah, that sounds
really hard. I mean,
in order to really write convincingly,
especially something like
fiction or nonfiction, something
more literary, you're,
there's so much that you have to know.
Dan. Kenny valley is a key issue.
I'm glad you brought that up.
Particularly as we get to
more and more immersive taps,
reality that if we create a
reality that's very different.
So one of the first animated movies, it
was Shrek. It's not really quite humans.
I didn't really attack the uncanny valley.
We get to more realistic
portrayals of animals and humans.
So we have that challenge.
Jungle Book.
I though was good at actually
leaped over the uncanny valley,
at least for animals.
It looked like a movie of animals,
but they were talking and the acting
and so it was clearly animation,
uh, can't quite do that
for humans yet. Uh,
in rogue one, uh, this one
character they brought back,
uh,
through animation.
I thought it was still in the uncanny
valley. Some people thought it was cool,
but I don't know.
There's a kind of uncanny valley,
not just for visual.
I think that's what you're getting at
is like there's some kind of stilted,
emotional thing going on
with, you know, when you,
if you talk to an AI and it claims to be
having this life, but you can just tell,
it's like you don't really have that life,
you know, that's a sort of narrative,
uncanny valley. And um, it
just sounds like levels.
It was interesting.
Dennis Hassabis at this beneficial
AI conference presented the Alphago.
He spent the whole presentation on this
one move in this key game that that
Alpha go played. Uh,
and it was a move off.
It was early in the game and it
played a move near the corner.
And any amateur knows you don't do that
because you need to control territory
and having a move that's right,
right near the corner.
Early in the game when you could really
try to begin to control some territory
doesn't make sense.
And everybody groaned at this.
And then at the end of the game,
it turned out that that was the
most brilliant move. It was key.
The AlphaGo wouldn't have one
without that amazing move.
Now I've been talking about how I think
when computers pass the Turing test,
they will be conscious.
And I talk about consciousness and my
books and it's not a scientific concept.
Do you need a philosophical leap of faith
as to who and what is conscious? But,
uh, so some scientists like
my mentor, Marvin Minsky, at
least at times, would say,
uh,
don't,
don't worry about consciousness is just
an illusion because it's not scientific
and there's no way to
have a falsifiable looks,
prime minister who and what is conscious,
my view is to can't abandon consciousness
because it's actually the fundamental
value in the world.
And our morality is based on
consciousness and unconscious entities,
only important insofar as they affect
the conscious experience of conscious
entities.
So you really need to make that leap
of faith in my leap of faith as if it
really is convincingly acts conscious.
Uh,
and you really are convinced it is having
the subjective experience of claims to
be, which is not the case yet. We'll
see how that they are conscious.
That's my leap of faith.
And so AI is when they really pass a valid
Turing test with emphasis on the word
valid. And that's a whole nother
discussion. Uh, will be conscious.
But my feeling was, I mean,
Alphago made this brilliant move.
I didn't feel like when they
made that move with a Ha,
I've got him here.
Uh,
and that there was a conscious
objective experience.
They went along with that which a
human would have had you saying, okay,
I'm going here and boy,
this is going to really shock them
and ultimately I'll be vindicated and
well, didn't have an emotional
investment in its victory. Yeah.
So, uh, it's interesting.
I mean I think if it's acting human and
certainly in the, and the world to go,
it was acting super human because not
even the human masters were shocked at
this move and ultimately
turned out to be the right one.
I didn't feel that Alphago
had a subjective experience
to go along with that.
You wrote a memoir about
some very personal stuff.
How do you make sure that when you're
writing about something so close to you,
you also, uh, have enough
distance to make it good art?
Yeah, that's a great question.
I mean that's probably part
of why it took so long.
You know, a lot of the experiences in the
book I was writing about as I was, um,
having them,
and then you have to let a certain amount
of time go by before you can really
say, okay, this is done.
And so I think maybe comics,
there's something about comics that
actually can be helpful because you put
yourself a reflection and Avatar of
yourself on the page and then it creates,
it takes on a life of its
own. Um, it's no longer you,
it's like a character that you've created
that's reflecting certain true things
about you, which is what fictional
characters do. Also. Um, maybe this,
the degrees of separation are
just, you know, slightly less here.
And so once I could really see
this character as separate from me,
even though they were a reflection of me,
that made it a lot easier
to edit and trim. Um,
and then also having readers helps,
you know, people who can say, ah,
this is bad. And you're
like, okay, you know,
you have to be quite
humble I think to do it.
Um,
and talking of consciousness,
it often seems very
vague. I often ask, uh,
what is consciousness but itself?
Um,
so I was wondering about how we
can elucidate that idea with,
uh, other elements like
reflective self awareness, uh, uh,
anything more concrete that we
can use to sort of put around it.
I've said that there's no machine you
could build that has a red light and a
green light and you're sliding into
Vienna. Okay. This one's conscious.
Now this one isn't,
that doesn't have some philosophical
assumptions built into it.
And so John's Searle at Berkeley
would want to make sure it's squirting
biological neurotransmitters.
Otherwise the greenlight wouldn't gone.
Dan Dennett would do moral
about what you've said,
which is to have a model of
its own thinking and to be
able to self reflect. Uh,
but you could imagine, uh, you
know, a, a Zombie that did that,
that was able to convincingly talk about
its own experience and you could build
a model of that today doesn't
necessarily mean it's conscious.
And so my conclusion is
it's a philosophical issue,
this to actually a role for
philosophy beyond science,
uh, but that we actually need to make
that philosophical leap of faith.
And we all make it to some extent.
Three,
assume other humans or conscious
is leads. Most other humans. Um,
most of the time, uh, people disagree
about animals. The whole, uh,
animal rights argument is a,
is about what,
whether animals are conscious
and to what degree. And uh,
I think Mike Cat was conscious.
Uh, not everybody agrees.
I think they didn't meet my cat,
but then we'll have arguments about
computers. That's the key thing. Uh,
John,
I'll make this a detailed argument.
How ridiculous it would be that a
computer program could be conscious and
there's was really nothing more
to his Chinese room argument,
which I won't recite now,
uh,
other than the absurdity that a set
of rules could, could be conscious.
But then I took his essay and I simply
substituted a symbolic manipulation for,
uh,
manipulating neurotransmitter
concentrations and made a
very convincing argument
that the human brain has no
consciousness, no understanding. And uh,
ultimately,
I mean the human brain is made of neurons
and we're understanding neurons is
machines somewhat complicated
but not that complicated.
And so the whole brain is a machine.
And where's the consciousness?
Where's the free? Well, um, so it,
it is a philosophical issue and I don't
think you have to be biological to be
conscious.
I mean,
it's also,
it comes down to being a kind of a
showing of art and empathy. Like if,
uh,
if the AI is convincing enough,
if it's like good enough of a writer
or you know, good enough of an artist,
it convinces you, and
that's what's important. Um,
and I think that's true for humans too.
I mean,
we read a lot of things and
we're not convinced. And, uh,
it doesn't mean that we think
that person deserves to die,
but we do discount how much credit we
give them and how much we're willing to
respect people if we aren't convinced
by how they communicate. And so it,
it seems like it's, you know,
that just in another substrate.
All right, well, thank you very much,
chuck.